when shooting around has been the  intensity level and making sure that  everybody is on the same page and just  dictating the pace right away coach  broker's now saying I want to make sure  that we dictate the pace by getting  early looks in transition this is  something where we understand we can get  more easy buckets and we have to make  sure that we're staying together and  focus on that category yes they're  short-handed but there are no excuses  with this group and he wants to continue  to build on the foundation of grit and  toughness guys we have a breaking  development Devon quartered and out of  his jersey on so Matt Dellavedova heads  onto the floor  and the Aussie will make this start Wow  very interesting a little bit excited  about starting the ballgame you forgot  about the Jersey